Hugh Hewitt talking to you from the
Kirby Center Hillsdale college's
flagship post outside of the United
States Capitol in Washington DC talking
you tonight about charter education K
through 12 and eight Ella town hall
hosted by me Hugh Hewitt host on the
Salem radio network and NBC as well as
MSNBC my friend dr. Larry on president
of Hillsdale College oh these many years
and Phil killed or who is the director
of the Barney charter school initiative
for Hillsdale which encompasses 17
schools in eight states to educating
8,000 students right now and we're here
to tell you a lot about why charter
education is flourishing in the public
domain and dr. R let's begin with you
you've come from Arkansas via Claremont
Graduate School
you've been at Hillsdale since the year
2000 why did you embrace charter school
as one of ills Dale's missions so public
education is a whole old and hallowed
thing in America and the only thing
that's been changed about it is the same
things been changed about everything in
government its bureaucratic now it's
rules from the top down more than half
the people who work in public education
are not school teachers and that number
has grown 760 percent since 1950 and the
number of students has grown 96 percent
so as part of the mission of the college
so is the reformation of K through 12
education so the truth is if you do
education according to the ways that
have been known how to do it you know as
mine used to say our guitar since Hector
the Greek hero was a pup then if you if
you use those hallowed ways which are
all made consonant with human nature
students will learn and so we happen to
know how to do that at Hillsdale College
and so we are sponsoring now 17 charter
schools and the number is growing now
what's important about people to know
tonight they can participate in it
there's a telethon Hall we will take
your questions via Facebook if you're
looking on Facebook right now or if you
press star 3 on your phone you can also
get in the queue to talk to dr. Arne and
Phil Kilgore Phil you're graduating the
United States Air Force Academy served
your country for nearly a decade now
you're an education why did you go and
join up with what began as
Barney Family Foundation grant in 2000
well the mission of Hillsdale College is
really what drew me to an association
with this fabulous institution and the
the idea that this could reach further
into the the K through 12 ranks was very
exciting my own children were enrolled
in a classical charter school and so
when dr. Arnn said that this was
something that the college would venture
was venturing into I was very excited
about that and the conversation took off
from there and you also have a 748
thousand dollar challenge grant which
one person could actually match tonight
but we'll take them in $10 donations
thousand dollar donations or up to seven
hundred forty-eight thousand dollars to
match that what will that money go to
people participate in helping to fund
the expansion of the initiative right
well are our efforts to help these
schools from the school standpoint its
artists all pro-bono because these
schools themselves their own operations
are publicly funded but the the service
and support that they get from Hillsdale
College is something that they cannot
get anywhere else it's very unique and
so this this provides support for the
college's outreach to these schools it
we provide consultation we provide
training so these are the things that
help these schools become great it
focuses on the boards the those that
leave the school and the teachers so
we're trying to help these schools
become great the wonderful kathleen
prepped me and she told me that you have
a manual that you actually execute from
the cost of setting them up to how do
you get a director how do you get a
board how do you find a principal i to
put to curriculum run through that phil
Kilgore and then I'll ask dr. run about
the curriculum and then we'll begin to
go again if you're in line go to star
three if you want to ask a question if
dr. are in fill Kilgore or go on
Facebook and type us up a question right
well this whole process begins with
local citizens who have passion for
education reform and understand the
classical education is really the things
going to change their their community
and provide this great support to
families there and so when a
conversation begins between us and and a
local group of citizens then we're able
to guide them in the the program that
we've outlined and we
help them with their application process
to an authorizer in their state so that
they could be granted to charter we also
have programs that provide training to
the those that will lead the school
that's that's a very special person who
has the ability to lead a classical
charter school and so we provide
specific training support to them and
then we provide teacher training as well
and this would be on the specific
curriculum that we have have designed
for these schools and so this is a it's
a it's a life cycle sequence that helps
these schools get on their feet and then
provides them support well into their
into the out years dr. on for years I've
been sending parents of precocious kids
to see you to actually come to your
office and put up with you for an hour
to talk about Hillsdale if someone's
listening tonight and they want their
kids in a charter school but they
haven't got one can they come to
Hillsdale and get started they can
especially if you're in one of the
states which is more than half the
states where the charter law is pretty
good then we know how to help you apply
and get your charter and I want to say
one thing to understand is that there's
only one thing you have to get right to
have a great school and that's
everything and it starts with what you
set out to teach and that's a beautiful
thing and a commanding thing the
teachers have to know what it is and how
to teach it and then the students have
to be told and they have to sign a code
and the teachers have to sign a code and
the parents have to sign a code that we
are going to undertake to learn these
things and then if everybody shows up a
volunteer and makes best efforts to
learn these things then the results are
magical I mean it's just they just take
off have you visited many of these 17
schools I've been to nearly all of them
Oh several more than once I will say
that one of them happens to be run by
the most important young academic in
America today my daughter dr. O'Toole
and and so of course I hear about that
one every week but I hear about them all
a lot and they're they're the same in
this way young people just remember a
young person is a human thing we all
grow up about the same rate and then a
teacher that's a that's a wonderful
to be my dad was a high school teacher
in Pocahontas Arkansas I'm a teacher
today it's a tremendous and joyous
undertaking but you have to take the
work seriously and it's great to have
help with people who really know a lot
about it and remember Hillsdale College
is soon 175 years old you've been doing
this bet we've been pretty good at this
for a long time fill Kilgore how do you
find a head of school we're gonna go
start taking people again if you want to
get in line start three on the phone or
your Facebook questions but how do you
find a head of school it's got to be the
hardest job if you haven't got dr.
Arden's gene pool to work with it is
very challenging well the good news is
is that Hillsdale College itself because
it it has such a great stature across
the country many people are aware of
what we're doing and and it draws
quality candidates to to our doorstep
but also within the schools we have
found a number of people who have been
in the classroom teaching who have what
it takes really to get on a leadership
trajectory and so we were able to find
excellent candidates from within the
school as well so those are those are
two great places let me emphasize if
you're listening and you want to start a
charter school Hillsdale will help you
if you want to help them help people you
can contribute online to this challenge
grant of seven hundred and forty eight
thousand dollars which we don't want to
go to waste we want it to get into the
initiative but now let's go online for
our first question to Joan oops it's
gone - on the phone Timothy from
Michigan has a question about common
core curriculum Timothy you're on with
dr. Arnn and Phil Kilgore I just wanted
to say you were doing a wonderful job at
Hillsdale College I serve on the
Washington our County Republican
Executive Committee and my question is
common core curriculum is it something
that the elections coming up we got Bill
Schuette running and I'm just wondering
is this something that we should try to
get rid of in Michigan yeah it's a in
the common core is not really common in
not really a core and what it does is it
does attempt to cover broadly everything
in history in science and English and
math but it does it while reducing all
of it into just a stream that goes by
and so there aren't any great moments in
history where you would focus like
Shakespeare for example who was you know
better than your average author yeah and
you know Socrates
made a mark you know back in his day and
so it's not organized to get to the
bottom of the importance of those things
and it and it also it turns the teacher
into a kind of robotic being detailed
instructions about what's to be done at
every moment so there's a lot wrong with
that thing and of course it ties into
this regime of high-stakes standardized
testing that we used to regulate
education these days and just remember
education happens in the mind and heart
of each student and the other people in
the room who are the other students and
the teacher so you should focus energy
on that so yeah we got to get rid of
that Tim now Phil Court Thank You
Timothy
Phil Kilgore we have a lot of parents
we're sending thousands of them and the
highest risk they have is the risk that
they take with their children so they're
obviously going to want them to be
educated well and in the good things but
they're also going to want them probably
to be able to get into Hillsdale College
when they're done with one of your
charters how many students progress from
your charter schools just to a good
college with a good curriculum well we
have had just a handful of graduating
classes since these schools you know
began and so we have had a couple of
students matriculate into Hillsdale
College and the thing that we we find
about that is they have seen a
continuity of their experience in these
schools into Hillsdale College because
there is the same underlying philosophy
that animates the the curriculum and the
instruction both institutions so it's
seamless for them about other schools do
they go on if they can't get into the
the Ohio State University for example
the the students are graduates you can't
get in there oh my pen slipped into your
leg our graduates have garnered some
excellent opportunities and scholarship
at impressive institutions
and so we are we are amassing some good
records right now even just in these
first two or three years graduating
class I get the point if you graduate
from one of these car charter schools
you are able to read Latin okay that's
it and then go anywhere and then
everybody has gone through at least
precalc
so you know scare anyone away it's hard
right I mean and I warn you do not make
the mistake of coming to Hillsdale cause
it's hard right but having said that
these schools generally have waitlist
larger than their student bodies how do
they cover the cost their public schools
correct right and so Phil Kilgore how do
they cover the cost well the the schools
themselves are funded by the state with
the per-pupil revenue that comes from
the state and so they have to be
efficient because they are typically
funded at about two-thirds to
three-quarters of what the regular
public schools do receive and so they
have to be efficient so correct me if
I'm wrong you provide them the keys to
open the door to public funding and then
the blueprint on which to build the
right architecture using that funding to
produce excellence in secondary
education that's correct I like the way
I put that on Facebook Eugene asks what
is the definition of a classical the
charter school Lari art well the word
classical is an interesting word its
cognate of course with the word class
and the classical things are the first
things that determine the class so when
we think of the Classical Age we refer
above all to attic grease in the Western
world and that means that it was
discovered there for the first time a
philosophy meant to be applicable and
give guidance to the good for every
human being regardless of their country
or their place so so and you remember at
the time Greece was in profound conflict
with Persia and they meant Persia to the
east so that the first school was
Plato's Academy and it was named for a
general named academic os-- who gave him
some land to hold his school so we hark
back to the original learning in the
West
world in the classical times and that
means we read those classical books and
all the great books that have come later
Phil Kilgore do you find yourself in
conflict with state authority over
conformance or non conformity to some of
the tedium of the modern bureaucratic
educational state well there has to be a
conversation between the school and the
state authorities so that the
obligations that the school does have to
the state are satisfied but don't also
compromise the the mission and
philosophy of the school so that
conversation is designed in order to to
work out points where there are
differences in alignment and those are
important conversations but so that
that's really the key the key factor
here and dr. I'll get you right in a
second Amy don't go anywhere from
California
Hillsdale is famously independent of all
federal money and ferociously so for a
variety of reasons which we talk about
weekly on my radio show in which people
can discover at Hillsdale dot e-d-u
how do you keep that independent spirit
in a public charter school which cannot
necessarily be independent of the public
school system well it of course there's
tensions all the time and Phil just
spoke very diplomatically we have to
maneuver through those but just remember
a school you know the the Northwest
Ordinance supplies the first federal
support for education in article three
and it says religion morality and
knowledge being necessary to good
government and the happiness of mankind
schools and the means of education will
ever be encouraged how do they fund it
they take 136th of the western lands
including Michigan where we are not
right now we're in Washington DC
Michigan where Hillsdale colleges and
they they leave that as an endowment to
be controlled by the states for
education in that Township and my point
is education has always been important
in America it used to be governed the
way everything else was from the bottom
up not the top down now charter schools
what that means where charter means
contract it means they have a separate
different kind of contract from the
regular public
and those contracts grant them more
independence and my own view I will tell
you is it rather than these high-stake
centralized testing we should only have
simple tests but above all we should
remember that schools are accountable to
the people who love the kids which means
it's a guarantee that that began in the
Northwest Territory the capital which
was Warren Ohio and I believe that if
you can begin the Riefler assha ng of
them out of Hillsdale that the system
that we presently have is close to
crumbling and I just want a quick
editorial comment I think it is so
fraught with cracks and so much
discussed about that that the revolution
there could be as quick and its
disintermediation from public
traditional education as uber was to the
taxicab Medina in New York - agreed Phil
:
I do parents respond to these kinds of
choices they're hungry for alternatives
sometimes it's a function of concern
about the school that their kids
otherwise would need to go to because of
safety issues or performance issues of
the school sometimes they simply
understand that another model is needed
they're drawn to the classical model
Larry are do you agree that public
education America is right for a
revolution yeah everything you said
except for the part about it happening
overnight we have to start on a long
road back to recovery to knowledge into
understanding you know we have
bureaucratized education that means
we're trying to manage it from the
center but the learning is local where
the kids are and the teachers are we
have to recover the dignity and
independence of teachers and parents and
students and it'll take a long time for
the system to adjust to that recovery
but it can start now and it can get
traction now we'll talk more about speed
but first let's go back to the phones I
would remind everyone on Facebook you
can type in your question if you wish to
give dr. Arne Phil Kilgore a question
via the phone hit star three on your
phone from the callin and it will happen
Amy is calling from California this
afternoon what skills and education are
required for someone starting a charter
school aim you want to expand on what
you're looking for there yeah probably
many people like myself in the audience
thank you
I could do that so what does it really
take for somebody that's interested in
getting involved Phil Kilgore well a
group of founders needs to have a
commitment to education recommending
frequently these these founding groups
are small five six seven people so we
don't need a large group just a very
committed core and committed to a set of
ideas if they're going to want to found
a classical charter school and I think
that really is where where it starts is
a fundamental commitment to an
educational philosophy and a desire to
really make a change in their community
so understanding what it takes to
establish a charter school in a
particular state laws are similar but
they're not uniform across the country
and so they need to understand what the
state would require of them they need to
understand I have a really good
understanding of the nature of the kind
of school that they would start with us
we lost Amy but what kind of people can
do this can they be moms who have
themselves matriculated but our outside
of the workforce now can they be dads
who've got fairly heavy workloads or
moms and dads who are both working
outside of that and let them give some
idea to the the audience the breadth and
depth of skillsets that you could use
Larry Ari well I heard Amy talk and I
read on your screen her question and I
will say that Amy could certainly do it
and did you hear the timbre and her
voice well yes the question I'd really
like to do that right well that's 90% of
them someone is piqued really go so Amy
sign up we're ready how do you sign up
Phil Kilgore well if someone has got
that kind of fire in their belly if I
can say that then they should contact us
they could express and under you know
what their ideas are about what they
want to do and and and we'll have a
conversation to make sure that we're
seeking to do the same thing everything
else Dale is available at Hillsdale dot
edu is there also a link there to the
charter school initiative yes that's on
the hell's Dell College website
Hillsdale dot edu from Facebook this
question will civics and American
history classes be a large part of this
program dr. Arnn it's kind of like the
high fastball that I'm hoping that Edwin
Onkar seoeon gets from the Indians
Hillsdale College we don't care about
that now you have to so here's one of
the things you learn in classic
philosophy our natural affinity for each
other
expresses itself in above all in the
formation of the political community
which is grounded in our ability to talk
to each other I'll take you through that
argument sometime it's very beautiful
and so people always live under law or
they live in chaos and therefore it
becomes an obligation of any educated
person to understand a politics and be
his own politics you need to know
politics generally so you can judge the
quality of your own and so of course we
study the Constitution of the United
States extensively in every school and
how it ought to operate not how it held
on race and you know as an informed
citizen today you have to you have to
make a contrast right we're in
Washington DC and today a couple of
colleagues might have been going around
talking to some important people and we
would like them to make the theme that
you know the laws used to be passed in
the Congress but last year the Congress
passed about 150 laws and yet
eighty-seven thousand pages were were
added to the Federal Register and that
means they were passed in these
regulatory agencies that really stand
quite outside the Constitution and there
are efforts underway to fix that so that
the laws could be minute so anyway the
point is you can't make an intelligent
judgment about that whatever you think
about that and there are respectable
arguments about why the new way is
better but the first thing is you have
to know that those two things are
different and so you have to start with
the original in order to lay down a base
of comparison so there will be civics in
American government I want to take this
moment to remind people there is a seven
hundred and forty eight thousand dollar
challenge grant that will go to the
Barney charter school initiative if it
is matched dollar-for-dollar if you have
a dollar to give or if you have 748
thousand dollars to give we'll take them
all but I'd also suggest you that if
you're in the testamentary gift this
position moment that is you're talking
to your lawyer about who do you want to
leave money to you want to talk to
Hillsdale dot edu go and find dr. Arnn
find Phil and not only match that Grant
but put it into a legacy that isn't a
building on some campus that will be
full of the anti-shah but will be
actually classically educating the next
generation of citizen Statesman's and
citizen just citizens actually bonnie is
calling from florida bonnie welcome
you're on with dr. Arne and Phil Kilgore
yes hello my question is how you can
instill the classical education in the
lower grades I think that's a good
beginning right there or is that part of
your program it's a terrific question
because people think of kindergarten and
squares on the ground and putting your
bumpers in the right Square how do you
do classical education Phil Kilgore with
a five year old well there I'll offer a
couple of things first of all history in
the lower elementary grades is really
quite robust in our schools and and very
fun because first graders study the
ancient Egyptians second grader study
ancient Greece third graders study
ancient Rome there you go have it at by
the end of the middle of the elementary
grades they've had a quick lower
elementary level overview of the world
of antiquity
they've got swords and pyramids later
all right they've got their imagination
going so if you go in mrs. Reardon this
class who's the kindergarten teacher in
the Leander Classical Academy in near
Austin Texas first of all it's awesome
how she teaches them because you know
kindergarten naturally kindergarteners
in a group naturally behave like snakes
in a bucket and so she has this thing
she says stack your blocks and then they
put their hand on top of their head and
they drag an imaginary string upwards
and their whole body straightens up so
the first thing you teach them is sit up
and pay attention then the second thing
like one day she says I can she's you
know awesome I happen to admire her very
much and been in her class several times
in flunked she says one day she's she
bright slowly on the board and she turns
around and they're all staring at
right they got their block stacked and
she says today we're gonna learn and she
starts spelling CA pa and she says
capacity and everybody goes ah I gotta
know what that is and by the time it's
over the first grade is about to be
invited over for an imaginary party she
says and she and she's got picture sizes
on the page at which picture would you
pick which one has the right capacity
they're learning science in five minutes
ago they were behaving like snakes yeah
that is and so that is let's go to Rick
in Colorado I love the fact that we're
geographically distributed in this tella
Town Hall all across the United States
and remember hit pound 3 if you want to
be on the phone like Rick or write it in
if you're on Facebook Rick what is your
question for Phil Kilgore and dr. Larry
art my question gentlemen thanks for
letting me on my questions about phonics
and why is it not used at least not in
the public schools I don't always use in
the charter schools but it seems like
it's the foundation at the elementary
school level for reading writing and
spelling for and also for giving
children the need to think or the way
they learn to think in small bits at a
time so Kilgore let's answer the second
question first is it used in the charter
schools absolutely that is the way to
teach young people how to read how come
we have to keep discovering that because
there's been a mindset and the schools
of Education for the last 50 years that
another way is preferred and that has to
be uprooted and we have to return to to
phonics as a as a clear way to be able
to teach kids how to read so in every
one of the 17 Academy is run by
Hillsdale College not run by but advised
by Hillsdale College dr. Larry are on
phonics is a Cornish yeah and the
collars made a perceptive implication
phonics is natural and it's easy to
understand why and when Aristotle is
explaining by the way why we're
political he says animals then use their
voices to indicate pleasure and pain
only human beings used theirs to
distinguish the just from the unjust the
advantageous from the disadvantageous
this gift of speech which is the same
thing in Greek the word for speech and
the word for reason it's the same word
that's our defining human trait
now here's what that means about phonics
when a kid gets to be 2 years old they
just start talking and nobody teaches
them to talk there's no place to start
and when they talk cup I'm looking at
things that are around me but name
something not that's a common thing cow
if you say that sound cow you know
there's a million cows and every one
slightly different from every other one
sometimes largely different and yet
two-year-olds learned that that abstract
noun stands for a whole class and
category of things and they just picked
that up they can just do that I like to
say in my family we were raised dogs and
children and they both live on the floor
and he eats food until about two years
old when the kids start talking and the
dogs never do now once they can talk and
they go to Clint kindergarten all you
got to do is show them the relationship
between the sounds they know and the
marks on the page and that's what funnik
Stas and very well oh yeah it really
works we are at the halfway point of our
tella Town Hall so I wish to reconfirm
for everyone if you've come in late
we're on Facebook and by phone tonight
with dr. Larry on president of Hillsdale
College all things Hillsdale available
at Hillsdale dot edu and Phil Kilgore
who is the director I want to say this
right of the barn a charter school
initiative
there's also 748 thousand dollar
challenge grant that you can be a part
of by going to Hillsdale dot e to you
and saying here's my hundred my five
hundred my five hundred thousand dollars
build these schools as fast as you can
and I want to go back over the basics of
what the initiative does and I might
actually ask dr. Arnn about the Barney
Family Foundation and why they started
this oh yeah so I got a great email
today from an old friend of mine and it
would be terrible with me to say the
name Herod Amundson but he said so you
named
initiative after a dinosaur and I
replied back dollar [ __ ] a fake dinosaur
yeah Steve Barney is a friend of ours to
college and he has a really great
characteristic he gets himself all
worked up and cries and he's a
successful man and so he got all worked
up one day about the fact that kids are
not learning in schools and he pointed
across the street at our school across
the street and he said they're being
deprived of their chance for a great
life and then he starts crying and
poking me in the chest with his finger
you you Larry aren't have to do
something about that and so I told him
that I had thought of an idea some years
ago presented to another fellow John
Walton who last died in a plane crash
and it was I said you know we're not
gonna go we're not you know we're not
put in the political business except in
the most profound way I said we're not
gonna go lobby the legislature we just
want them to leave us alone
but there are these charter schools and
we could help to make them good and he'd
be odd for us to do that because we're
we don't take any money from the
government colleges do sometimes get in
the charter school business and they
make some money from it so we don't get
any money from these charter schools but
I said you know maybe that would help
keep our motives clean so he loved that
idea and he made a major gift to that
has recently made another one and he's
you know he's not an infinitely wealthy
man but he's wealthy and he's been very
generous to this thing hats off to mr.
Bari yeah that's off let me go to
Facebook because this segue is quite
nicely from mark on Facebook is there a
blueprint for a ground-up
Barney charter school startup fill kill
boy is there a blueprint well there's a
blueprint in the fact that we have a
scope and sequence for the academic
program the the advice that we give the
counsel that we give for founding group
says they're coming together a lot of
times as a function of the local
conditions where they live but we know
the general pathway that is that a group
must must travel in order to get a
school open so
that all that information goes into
their application we work with groups
right now that are exactly in the in the
midst of this process and so it the
blueprint itself is targeted toward the
kind of school that we're trying to
somebody's got the tingle right now
they're thinking I can do this and I'm
gonna go to Hillsdale dot edu and find
this Kilgore guy or get ahold of iron
how long's it gonna take them from
tingle to touch down for the high school
football team maybe when did they open
the doors well I've never seen it happen
in less than two years from the initial
inspiration thing to a doors opening
okay because several key things have to
happen and the the state authorizer has
a big piece of that process where the
group goes through the review and
approval process with the state
authorizer but the founding group itself
must form they must write an application
they need to go through that process
with or authorizer and then once that
happens they need to get ready to get
the doors open which there's a lot of
details associated with that so two
years we've seen some three sometimes
four four particularly difficult
circumstances and a good tenacious group
they'll just stick with it and get the
job done perfect segue to on the phone
and I remind people who are listening
star three I'll say that twice for the
people who are from Pittsburgh star
three and then you'll get through oh we
have someone from Pittsburgh Wendy from
Pittsburgh how are you I'm giving you a
hard time cuz I'm a Browns fan Wendy and
we're jealous what originally from
Youngstown oh there you go steel Valley
stealing the soul killing is fun what's
your question
listen my question is what about the
teachers what are you looking for and
with regard to the people who are
teaching in these schools dr. Larry I
will let you talk about teachers because
you are one love they need love and if
they love their subject then they will
know it and if they love the students
then they will know how to bring those
two things together I was told something
which i think is marginally true but
probably if you don't love calculus you
never had a great calculus teacher and
if you don't love physics you never had
a great physics teacher I barely got out
of physics in high school I did all
right in calc
so I put that down did you agree with
that gentleman No
so this term a good friend of mine is
here in Washington and we haven't seen
him much lately but we're both teaching
Aristotle's ethics at our separate
colleges right now it's a hard book it's
it is it's hard but also it's wonderful
and I have never ever I've never seen
anybody who didn't start reading that
book with difficulty but I've never seen
anybody who after an hour of talking
about it with somebody who understands
it doesn't go wow it's scary how great
that book is and when and what comes to
you when you see what he's saying and
then soon enough by the way you'll see
it for yourself is what comes to you as
he is describing the whole structure of
the universe and where you fit in it and
how you're to live in it and what I want
people are watching to take away and we
get this each week when we do the
Hillsdale dialogue is that you get
excited about your children living this
life they don't go through a grind at a
charter school if it's a good charter
school they go willingly and with joy
and they come back educated and
knowledgeable and occasionally feel
virtuous they do they do the idea of
moral character something that is front
and center at these schools they
understand that it's important for the
schools to bring knowledge in order to
furnish the minds of these young people
with understanding of the human world in
the natural world but they also realize
that they're shaping the character of
these people so that they can when they
finish their time at these schools move
into adulthood and understand what it
means to be a fine citizen and a good
husband and a good a good mother a good
employee all of these kinds of things
are important and so the teachers
understand that virtue that the
character all these things are the
lessons that are lifted out of the
curriculum day in and day out
I think of 8,000 students and that's the
total number currently in the charter
school initiative the Barney charter
school initiative they have ahead of
them life spans of 60 70 and 80 years so
you're actually eight thousand times
eighty number a year
of citizenship it's a big undertaking we
get a lot bigger with support
don't forget our challenge grant of
seven hundred and forty eight thousand I
used to work for PBS so I can do
challenge grants all night long let's go
back to Facebook Kate do your charter
schools use technology in the classroom
I'll go with you first there is a use of
technology in the classroom it's it's in
a modest fashion it's something that is
done in order to never let it supplant
the authority of the teacher in the
classroom it's the human being that
teacher in front of the classroom that
teaches the students not the technology
but it is a tool that from time to time
comes in handy I've been on hills dales
campus enough to know that technology is
not a phobia there nor a fetish yeah
well you know I'm a gadget guy and so I
like all that stuff but respect their
gadget you come to my area yeah you know
but I mean you know what do I read I
read Aristotle's ethics on the on the
Amazon Kindle or the iPad so the main
thing is the focus should not be on the
manner that you discover a thing I like
technology because I travel all the time
I don't like to have all my stuff with
me but but on the other hand the stuff
is the stuff right so I teach Aristotle
when I teach Winston Churchill and I
teach America well I know about those
things that I've got them with me all
the time Hillsdale dot edu slash
townhall if you would like to make it
get Hillsdale dot edu slash townhall we
make it easy for you to be a part of
this revolution in education let's talk
about physical plant Phillip you need a
building you can't just do this over the
Internet
how do you find buildings how do you
find the place that can accommodate an
expanding group of students parents
teachers that's one of the great
challenges that are found in group faces
because depending on where they are
there may not be many options so we've
seen this play out in a number of
different settings the the group needs
to determine how they're going to
finance their facility they've got to
pay for those expenses out of their
operating budget to help them figure
that out we have conversations with them
about that and and can help point them
in the direction of where some sources
of that kind of financing and funding
might be
but the good news is is that again
because local governance local control
is one of the the primary principles
they know their lay at a land in their
particular community much better than we
possibly could and so they know where
there might be facilities where where
something might be an effective place in
another location that might not be so
great so I want to say something else
about that so in that that wasn't
satisfied with that film although Phil
is the greatest guy in the world so
first of all in principle here's the
fact in principle you can take 65 to 75
or 80 percent of the money that the
public schools get and you can use the
resort and use that money to fund not
only your operations but also your
capital cost and that means in most days
I did not know that so in most states
the money is there right and that you
know as long as you get enough kids in
the school and so that means that you
can in principle and most of our schools
do fund their building out of their
operations and that means you can get a
Lindor or the best thing of all is fine
some fine person who wants to help you
who's got a building or got some money
or knows how to do that sort of stuff
but you the point is the resources are
there to put that together I'm curious
every bishop in America who's closed a
Catholic school ought to be calling you
and saying we'd like you to use our
closed Catholic school have they used
any of you repurposed build buildings
anywhere yet in a few places yeah well
Clarence Thomas went to school for two
years in Savanna Pius the tenth it's now
Savannah Classical Academy tada I went
to Pius the tenth I'm not a justice of
the Supreme Court no does not guarantee
that back to the phone from Florida Moe
would you give us your question for Phil
Kilgore and dr. Larry Arnold
okay this is Moe you say yep go ahead my
little tape delay there just speak into
the phone okay thank you so much time to
ask a question I would like to see this
as a national debate I watched
News on a regular basis and there are
all kinds of debates and things going on
from football players kneeling down the
tax plan and all kinds of things but I
don't see our department of education
secretary lady up there being
interviewed I don't see the national
debate on this issue of charter and
voucher programs versus other kinds of
education what can we do to get this to
be a national debate bring it to the
awareness of the average guy out there
you know that's a great question mo and
I will say over the years I've been in
media since 1989 intermittently efforts
have been made to have the so-called
debate I'm using air quotes if you're
just listening and you're not watching
on television because the debate is
actually cyclical it comes and it goes
as people grow frustrated but it never
gets traction I think what might put a
part the Barney initiative is that it's
a real deal that's happening it's not a
debate about whether or not to happen
you put aside the debate you're just
doing it yeah I think of this so first
of all there is of course a huge debate
though about how we're not what kind of
government we're going to have that's
everywhere all the time the media is
one-sided about that in the main but and
so the question of shall we continue
with the bureaucratic form or shall we
have the constitutional form that's a
big question now that the education
system is a subset of that right because
if you just let schools run let parents
be sovereign and let local people run
them they can get help from people like
us and you know K through 12 education
is not rocket science and you can make
it great if you get the elements right
we can help you with that you can make
it great I want to emphasize again if
you go to Hill tale dot edu slash town
hall and make a contribution that will
be matched and if everybody watching
this or listening to it right now does
$100 gift will hit the match in no time
at all if you or more you do more but
just you say $100 that's a lot of money
it is but the energy you put into the to
transforming the American education
system is remarkably obvious and
available to you Hillsdale dot edu slash
town hall on Facebook Chris
how are these charter schools different
from other charter schools available
it's a great question for both of you
fill up and then dr. are how are they
different
well charter schools in general each
will have its own organizing principle
there are charter schools for the Arts
there are charter schools that are some
focus on science and technology these
focus on classical education and so
having an understanding of the
fundamentals that this is this balance
across these four core disciplines of
math and science and history and
literature and that Latin is taught and
that moral character is something that
is a front and center these these
fundamental characteristics of these
charter schools these classical charter
schools are what distinguish it from
many other charter schools Larry well
it's a it's a the Barney charter school
initiative schools are a community and I
we haven't mentioned one of the most
exciting things about it in the summer
teachers from these schools last year
400 or so they come up for a week to 10
days staggered over three or four weeks
different groups board members come one
week head masters come young school
teacher okay kindergarten through third
grade come and they culminate they spend
time together and they spend time with
our faculty and you know our faculty a
bunch of them have just adopted this
stuff right there's a game theory guy
with a Berkley degree in our math
department and he's becoming an expert
on how to teach basic math to little
kids right and he's because they just
really love this and so the Faculty of
the college and the teachers and they
had masters they spend an intense time
together getting better and helping each
other do that and that's becoming very
powerful force and it's gonna grow as
the number of schools gross let me ask
you about pay for your teachers and let
me ask you about discipline for your
students because these are two of the
problems that percent Catholic education
through the 50s and the 60s Roth doubt
that wrote about it be it was the death
of the Catholic school system that they
could not keep up financially even
though there were the religious orders
decline they just couldn't keep paying
it and discipline was always the draw
but then that began to decline so how do
you deal with pay for teachers Phillip
and what do you do about discipline
first
well all the schools are very desirous
of paying the teachers competitively
because they want to reward the
commitment that the teachers have made
to the schools and so they have to make
their budget balanced so that's an
important feature as well and so these
teachers are there they're paid close to
on par with what some of the the regular
public school pay scales which go up
precipitously upward if that if that is
the right description these schools will
will try to make sure that these
teachers are rewarded as well but we
also find a wonderful thing going on is
that the teachers themselves are so
committed to this that if there is a
little bit of a gap between what they
could make elsewhere in a public school
and what they're making here many of
them are pleased to be able to actually
do what they got into the profession to
do in the first place which is have the
freedom to teach if that requires
discipline the second part of the
question dr. Arendt and you've been
disciplining Hillsdale in an unusual way
for since 2000 which is not a heavy hand
but a set of rules to which people
commit well you know if you've got the
death penalty than everybody else then
they learn now so it's getting the young
especially about matters of their
passions running away from them which is
most discipline problems come from that
they have to agree so everybody has to
take it and sign an honor code to come
to these charter schools and that means
they and their parents have signed up
for this and that means they have to be
good now when they're really young on
the one hand they don't really
understand when they first start out
what that commitment is but on the other
hand they're not very likely to be
terribly unruly like simply wriggle all
the time so yeah the point is the
culture of the school just remember why
would we want the parents to sign a code
the answer is schools are places where
people cooperate to learn so you got to
get everybody on the same page and then
they thrive and then when there's a
problem like you know and I'm
you know I I work in a college and you
know it's a fancy College and but we
make a contract with the parents and
then when after you know when they split
them up at freshman convocation and the
mothers leave their children behind for
the first time right and they all bawl
like babies and the kids walk away and
pretend to be sad to miss them but then
we take him upstairs and we give him a
nice dinner before we sent him off alone
to home and I always tell him same thing
always tell him you know if your kid
calls and he's mad at us you're on our
side you can find out later if we messed
up and if we did we'll fix it
but you're on our side right in any
dispute which are uncommon until start
college but still and so you got to give
that advice and then people are helping
each other in the school and the school
advances no I think it is unnecessary
unless people have not known of
Hillsdale Hillsdale derive from the
abolitionist movement it is without
regard to race color gender it is a
place of freedom loving people combining
to the common purpose are the charter
schools in the same traditional area
well charter schools are and they admit
by lottery and that means that you know
there be in one school than one I happen
to know the most about they had about
three times as many initial applications
as they could take and how old is that
school that school is in its fourth year
there's one worth year right and that
means that in the beginning right and so
you know the headmaster
dr. O'Toole my daughter she called me up
and she said that was terrible and I
said what and she said well they flashed
up on the screen the list was a computer
program and it and you start reading
down the names and they can see that
only the people above the red line got
it and the red line is very high on the
page and people just gasped right so
then in the second round when you have
openings they to have to be admitted by
by lottery so they allow siblings to go
they do they what's the answer that
the law varies from state to state
sometimes it is permitted it's better if
you can do that right and you know in
Hillsdale College by the way there's not
automatic entry for siblings but you
know they get you know we we would
rather you're aware of them yeah anyway
it's a qualification not an impediment
and you know the curse of Hillsdale
College is some preacher who's got 11
children and they're all so bad because
they don't have any money and we're
gonna have to pay to educate them but
that happens I can tell you I'm sure you
want to know the family names I got them
on the tip of my tongue but yeah so you
want to you remember you're building the
culture and the college can help with
that because that's what we do and you
know we have our private Hillsdale
Academy that's now about 25 years old in
a really great private school right off
the campus at Hillsdale and so we
learned a lot from that but we're
learning faster from this because this
is a big thing on the phone
Janie from Wisconsin Janie welcome
you're talking to Phil Kilgore the
director of the Academy initiative of
the the Barney charter school initiative
and dr. Larry I'm president of Hillsdale
College go ahead Janie hi guys how's it
going I'll make it quick
Hillsdale is kind of near and dear to
our family we have a daughter who's a
junior there right now and she loves it
we'll be there in a couple weeks to see
her what's what's your last name sir
Denning oh yeah yeah okay yeah well
great
well I we're on the air so I can't
really say the usual joke what a fine
young woman she is how does the charter
school or charter schools in general how
do they address like music programs and
sport you know they have a sports do
they have music programs at a charter
school and how do they address the cost
to cover such things Philip go right
ahead there so the sports are very
important to these schools athletics
fitness all of these all the schools
have engage in those as part of the the
program the arts are very important as
well they're an integral part of the
curriculum and so
all of that is important in his Impreza
at these schools sometimes there are
some expenses you know if and the
schools might do some fundraising to be
able to buy musical instruments or to
buy drama props so some athletic
equipment so there there's some extra
support that they are going to reach out
to the community to get but these are
these are important facets of the life
it's the golden view Classical Academy
in Colorado I was there not long ago
Phil's there the same day the lower
school music teacher is a graduate of
Julliard and so helps and so the upper
school music teacher I don't know where
she went to school but we sit in her
class and she's got them she plays bits
of music and there they're identifying
the music and they're talking about it
how a difference from another piece that
they said the point is there it's just
awesome
I think that's common you can start one
of these you can support all of them
again you go to Hillsdale dot edu slash
town hall to make a contribution we have
a 748 thousand dollar challenge grant
your $10 or $100 or $5,000 your seven
hundred forty eight thousand dollars
tonight will help us so please go and do
that and you can also hit pound three if
you want to get a question as we begin
to wind down here we can't skip
questions from Ohio it is written on the
stone tablets of wisdom holly is from
ohio your question for Phillip Kilgore
and dr. Larry re good evening gentlemen
thank you for taking my question I'm
watching the tribe game I think they
gave up a run which is not good but uh
and my youngest son's name is Hugh Oh
but my question is kind of if I'm my
kids are growing up if my husband and I
were ever to do this we live in
Cleveland we live in a nice suburb I
would be interested I'm really
interested in getting the kids who
aren't exposed to this kind of education
involved more
I would rather you know see the school
put in a lower income area or somewhere
where we could draw some kids who don't
have access to this I do understand what
the signing of the contract that you
know by the parents and the kids it
might make it a little
are difficult but do you have any
schools that are already in those kind
of areas or could that work you know
where it's not like my kids and I'm
bringing kids and they're just three so
good question three of the seventeen and
one more opening next year in New Mexico
are are in what we call what do we call
them urban schools and that means that
those problems that you name are there
those are difficult they make it hard
for the student those are harder schools
to do we're very committed to it it
takes longer for them to get to a level
of excellence but they get there and
they're very worth the time and effort
and also at the college we've we've been
raising money for the Frederick Douglas
scholarships if you met the very great
man Frederick Douglas friend of Abraham
Lincoln he would give you a visiting
card with this picture on it a photo of
him on it and that photo was taken in
our oldest building in Hillsdale College
so we was a visitor to our campus twice
we're very proud of that and so we have
scholarships now for kids who've grown
up in difficult circumstances we don't
care what color they are any color is
great by us but and so we are making an
effort not just to help them through
these charter schools but also to help
them go to a really fine college so Phil
Kilgore could a third party not a parent
be an organizer for an inner-city school
absolutely in fact the majority of the
members of these founding boards are not
parents they're local citizens so it's
it's a combination of all those in the
community that care so if you really
wanted to make life's work you could try
and get one of these things going you
need a band of brothers and sisters and
they'd have to get together and work
with you but you could make that your
passion absolutely you could organize it
back on to Facebook at this time let's
talk to Mary how do you find classically
trained teachers felt Kilgore how do you
recruit the teachers you need at these
schools well you go to great colleges
like Hillsdale College and and you look
at the the graduating class and find out
who's interested in teaching and and
start to whet their appetites
for the kind of thing that they can
continue to do and love learning and
have a fabulous academic atmosphere that
they would continue to work in so great
liberal arts colleges are fabulous post
poach I would never confess to poaching
if someone comes and approaches us
because they're drawn to it like a moth
to a flame absolutely we would open the
doors to two great candidates they can't
just use just graduated teachers you've
got to have people or maybe you can but
I would assume you need some people to
help teachers learn how to teach so
there there are two bottlenecks right
there's a lot of it the reason this can
this revolution this revolution is
starting it's underway and it's you know
God grant it's going to go far but the
reason it can't happen overnight is that
it takes time to learn you know to get
good teaching the best things across the
ages in all the disciplines and so not
everybody is a school teacher gets that
kind of education anymore indeed there
is active pressure from State
Department's of Education to stop that
kind of thing the state standards help
to obstruct that kind of thing so
there's a lot of problems there right
and on the other hand colleges that do
teach that stuff are thriving these days
we are and so more and more and is
there's more demand if you understand
basic economics then there will be more
supply if there are more places to teach
that allow you to teach the right way
and support you in doing so you'll draw
more people to the profession if you're
a graduate of Hillsdale College if
you're senior we have a jobs fair a
college fair cut what did we call it
classical school job fair cut classical
job fair and right so we graduate three
hundred twenty kids and we get you know
45 or 50 schools show up and everybody
and they do it in the student union so
the kids walk by it on their way to
meals and if you stop by in there and
see those people and they've got Mar
they the schools bring marketing
materials and if you're a kid you know
and you can walk and chew gum at the
same time you can't offered four or five
jobs by the time you get out of there
because they the raw material is there
and they will teach you to teach
well let's pick up the pace we get to
everyone we can helen is calling from
Georgia Helen welcome to the teletón
hall Hillsdale dot edu slash town hall
if you want to make a contribution start
three if you want to ask a question in
facebook if you want to do it online on
the phone Helen from Georgia go ahead
Helen
hey this is Helen Adams I so appreciate
you taking my call I am just curious as
a retired
instrumental music teacher what fine
arts programs you have in the curriculum
chorus Orchestra band what all is really
involved in the curriculum oh is it up
to each individual school job killer in
the K through 8 grades there is an an
academic element of the curriculum for
every grade in music and in fine arts
and that those music teachers also
incorporate some performance as well
into the high school and in the the
middle school and the high school grades
choir band orchestra they may not get
them all launched in the first year the
first two years but they'll likely get a
little choir launched in the first year
and instruments will follow shortly
thereafter dr. you know they all have
that thank you for the question
you know music soothes the savage beast
so you do have boys in these schools but
athletics you've also - man oh your
parents want to know can can their
swimmer swim can their runners run can
their football players pass catch block
tackle you've had a couple NFL people
come out of Hillsdale I'll have you know
I trained playing right now yeah a
recruiting system for Hillsdale line
yeah it if so sports is important
because human beings have this body
that's like the bodies of animals but
they have an immortal soul in it and the
soul and the body are connected and
interrelated the human being isn't it a
integrity of body and soul and so you
have to use your body you have to learn
to be good at it you have to pursue
excellence in regard to that understand
what the challenges are to that so of
course everybody does athletics and I
will also taste something funny and
really important to know and that is
athletics is you know PE and exercise
and sweat is really good for kids and it
helps them think and it fights
depression and it clear
the mine let me get the last question
and then I'll come back and wrap up for
everyone by reminding you but I'll tell
you right now if you go to Hillsdale dot
edu slash town hall you can contribute
there's a matching grant of seven
hundred and forty eight thousand please
do it tonight
as you watch this cuz you're moved and
you think I want to be a part of that if
you want to start the school go to
Hillsdale dot edu and find the town hall
go to he'll tell daddy to you and find
the charter school initiative and get in
touch with Phillip David is from
Philadelphia you get the last question
you're on the phone David welcome thank
you you may not want this is the last
question but Thomas all wrote an article
three days ago called 30 blocks of back
to school about a West Philadelphia
school and my question really is in that
context it's a phenomenal article
incidentally you some incredible writer
as you may know my question is because
we have so many national problems as
somebody some others have said before to
do with race and everything under the
under the Sun where is the linkage if
there is one between these charter
schools that you're talking about and
the public school system at large and he
gives you all kinds of statistics here
to do with blacks Hispanics white so on
what the mean SAT scores are you know
who scored how many in terms of average
of percentages on those numbers and so
on how do you guard against having an
even greater gap even though the public
school system is in disarray generally
which he points out in many ways here by
the way in this article it is anybody
worried about out or we just hope you
know so so if I understand you right and
David thank you for the question dr.
Souls a friend of dr. aren't you're
worried about the charters being too
good in the gap going to great is that a
concern I'm worrying about I don't know
there's another book that I the other
Wes Moore I don't know if you know Wes
Moore at all but
he came from Baltimore in a black area
had a another person with the same name
about a few blocks away his friend ended
up in prison for the rest of his life
for murder and the West Moore who wrote
the book ended up being a Rhodes Scholar
in a Johns Hopkins graduate and so on
and so forth but has done very well so
my point is how do you let me read you
just one quick code I know we're short
on time we are short here and waited
this article starts the problem isn't
that Johnny can't read the problem isn't
even that Johnny can't think the problem
is that Johnny doesn't know what
thinking is he confuses it with feelings
unquote okay so the more you look at
American society the more you see people
who cannot fake or don't know what
thinking really entails in a classical
sense so I don't I don't see how that
ties to the question you were asking
about race because I've never yet seen
anybody either thinking or feeling with
their skin I think you think and feel
with your soul a rational soul and the
only thing we can do about that is teach
people that that ain't so and so you got
to learn to think and you know I will
tell you I happen to teach I'm teaching
right now Aristotle's ethics and one of
the greatest and most beautiful
teachings about that is that every good
choice by every human being comes from
an interplay of right thinking and right
desiring and in a in a ordered soul
which it is our purpose in these
classical school schools to produce the
desires come into a court with the
thinking and so they can both reason to
the right thing and then they want to do
it and that's the whole key to becoming
a thriving human being so to summarize
the Barney Family Foundation began in
2000 with a generous grant the Hillsdale
College which you can now be a part of
with the challenge grant of seven
hundred forty eight thousand you can
call the number eight hundred four three
seven twenty to sixty eight eight
hundred for thirty-seven 2268 one more
time for the Steelers fans eight hundred
four three seven twenty to sixty eight
well you can go to Hillsdale dot edu
town hall to help and please do help
tonight part of the revolution a couple
of kind of closing comments from both of
you Phillip Kilgore it is your job to
Shepherd the Barney charter school
initiative what do you love people to
take away from our conversation what I
want them to take away is that this is
having a fabulous impact on local
communities on families and and
ultimately on the nation and this is
something that inspires hope because
we're seeing the right things happen at
the very grassroots level of what this
nation needs most and I am inspired
every day that I work with these schools
and see what's happening in the
classrooms dr. I well you know learning
is the highest thing and learning about
the highest things is the highest kind
of learning and to open young people to
that is the key to all their future
happiness and character and citizenship
so this is the thing that will work and
it's going to spreading very far and it
will provide an example and if the world
will listen to that example we can
return to our glories and if you are
thinking one of two things act on if
you're thinking I could do this you can
do it go to the website if you're
thinking out to support this you should
support it tonight call 1-800 437 2268
I'll go to Hillsdale ddu slash Town Hall
thanks to Kathleen and a crew of seven
thanks to everybody who's listening on
the townhall tella Town Hall who are
watching on Facebook live streaming the
technology behind this is amazing and
you can learn that at a Hillsdale
charter school initiative at the Barney
charter school initiative thank you
tonight thank you every day that you'd
do something in Hillsdale dded you and
we'll be back for another Town Hall
sometime soon